it's a mystery
great whites around the world have been
attacking divers in cages
no one knows why this is
frightening finally
dr greg scomo may have cracked the case
he thinks the sharks are chasing bait
they want to tease these sharks in tight
to the cages
but that shark is going to be
disoriented
but there's a problem with greg's theory
one case
doesn't add up what's going on here it's
clearly ignoring that first bait
and that first bait's actually pulled
away from it
this great white seems to ignore the
bait it goes straight for the divers
no you gotta understand there's a lot of
scent in the water so this shark is
moving right around let me slow things
down here
but look again another clue
the shark goes to the back of the cages
and there you go
right there there's a bait box behind
the cage
and the shark is checking out the bait
box this highlighted bait box is full of
chum
it sends a powerful scent to the shark
but it's confused it can't see any fish
what's happened here is as it
accelerates toward that box it realizes
there's no room for it the shark turns
but it's too late to avoid the cage
these are big animals
yeah they're fish that are incredibly
agile in the water but not when they're
this size
you don't want to put the baits this
close to where people
are diving
there's a way to test if greg's theory
is correct
by seeing how sharks react to cage
divers
when they are drawn in by something
other than bait
in australia marine biologist melissa
marquez
and boat operator matt waller will
attempt to attract sharks
using music
this experiment is a real opportunity
for us to learn something new
melissa wants to see for herself if
great whites will still attack a cage
when drawn in by something other than
bait
good to go as if there's other stimuli
such as just vibrations and there's not
food
they might act a little bit different
i'm gonna put her in the cage we're
gonna hand her our underwater speaker
[Music]
melissa thinks music with low
frequencies will best
pique the interest of the sharks but
will it also lead them to
ram the cage what kind of frequencies
are we talking around
40 hertz
[Music]
coming your way get ready to rock out
[Music]
a big great white comes in not following
its nose or its eyes
[Music]
travels four times faster underwater
than it does through air
and great whites have ears to hear it
a small ear hole sits behind each eye
they are able to
[Music]
[Music]
the shark comes in to check out the
concert but shows no aggression at all
[Music]
it's evidence that no bait means no risk
of a cage attack
acoustic attraction may offer the
benefits of bait
without the risks
[Music]
do you think we're crazy or we're
actually onto something maybe different
here
we're seeing results here and like a lot
of things with very white sharks more
research has got to be done
you